foreign
[Music]
[Music]
can you open your eyes my superhero in
days are over
great
[Music]
wow
hey guys guys guys guys guys guys I hate
to break up whatever the hell this is
but listen we need your help to win the
battle I am hoping win the battle at
this purposely will drag it out
do nothing on just me he has seen many
he loves perish he feels their blood is
on his hand all right you know what fine
you sit here let's go
this way they'll make a statue of me
when I save the planet
you stay there and don't be a hero
right hold on
[Music]
wouldn't hurt to go and help those
innocent people down there
let's get through it shall we
okay but
okay come on climb aboard
come on people are dying
okay you won
here we go
okay count of three jump one two three
sometimes it just doesn't want to work
off
yeah
you're wasting time come
[Music]
on
there's a maniac who seeks to end us all
and putting together the greatest team
ever are you packed
[Music]
we've got cold he's my best friend yes
there's my ex-girlfriend Jay
Valkyrie this is the best day of my life
big audience
and giant goats look at those they are
wonderful yes they are they also scream
quite a lot
[Music]
[Music]
I said it was going to be like a
relaxing holiday
[Music]
thank you